there's always like those negative
comments mixed in so it's hard to not
see them
charlie demilio is keeping it real with
her fans revealing that she's battling
an eating disorder the 16 year old
tiktok star posted this message to her
instagram story on thursday
she says she knows it can be so
uncomfortable to open up to friends and
family about having an eating disorder
but she hopes she can be a voice when it
comes to issues about body image
quote i've been afraid to share that i
have an eating disorder
but ultimately i hope that by sharing
this i can help someone else
i know eating disorders are something
that so many other people
are also battling behind closed doors
now's a good time to focus on myself and
making sure i'm happy and healthy and as
well as everyone else so i feel like
that's more important than feeding into
the negative comments
the social media personality continued
by apologizing to fans for making a now
deleted tick tock video
dancing to prom queen by beach bunny a
track that's been called out for
insensitive lyrics like
shut up count your calories and wish i
was like you
blue eyed blondie perfect body charlie
wrote in her post that she never meant
to hurt anyone with her song choice
that could have triggered you she
explained quote i deeply and truly
apologize and hope you know that i never
intended to cause you harm
there's people in there that really do
like watching my videos and enjoy me
posting and i want to be able to give
back to them and like their comments
reply so it's
it's hard but i'm i'm working on it
charlie's post concluded by
encouraging fans to seek help if they
need it she even included a swipe up
link to the website for the national
eating disorders association
it's not the first time that charlie has
spoken out about body image
in april she slammed trolls online for
commenting on her appearance
charlie tweeted quote stop talking about
my body
it's not your place to tell me if i'm
losing weight or gaining weight
she continued writing that it's never
okay and encouraged fans to be
respectful
it's like um body image and you know
just things like that were really hard
for me to handle at first because i
wasn't used to that
charlie isn't the only tick tock star
getting candied about body shaming
19 year old addison ray told et earlier
this month that she
too has been a victim of it i like
noticed myself
getting like super hard on myself about
it and like letting that get to me and
it's kind of just
a part of growing through it and just
being like look this is who i am this is
who i was meant to be and i can't let
people that don't truly know
the real me in my heart you know and
haven't met me
um kind of determine how i feel about
[Music]
myself
[Music]
you